[Musique]
s'en souvient comme si c'était hier
jamais il n'aurait imaginé une telle
agressivité à l'entrée de son commerce
l'entreprise familiale subit encore les
contrecoups du des financement de la
police de Burlington en 2020
le Parti progressiste dont fait partie
youjin Burgman depuis les années de
Burny senders à la mairie vote pour des
financer la police municipale de
Burlington oui
l'objectif est ambitieux réduire de 30%
le nombre de policiers au rythme des
départs à la retraite sont mis à pieds
expect
les effectifs passent de plus de 90
officiers à moins de 60 en l'espace de
quelques mois c'est la démission massive
des policiers qui est venu brouiller les
cartes
en main sachant que les policiers moins
nombreux priorisent les appels urgents
oui Frost de backs
les infractions mineures à commencer par
les vols à l'étalage
pour protéger les commerçants la ville
tente de corriger le tir mais l'embauche
de nouveau policiers s'avère laborieuse
dans un contexte de pénurie de main
d'oeuvre
le bilan est mitigé mais de nouvelles
initiatives voient finalement le jour
depuis quelques mois des agents
communautaires sillonnent les rues sans
armes Justin
ironie du sort le budget de la force
policière grimpe à nouveau et s'approche
de ce qu'il était avant son des
financement
si la situation s'améliore enfin peu à
peu aux yeux de marque il aurait préféré
que cette expérience n'est jamais lieu
[Musique]